[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días este
es un contenido 100% dedicado al
continente africano mi nombre es andrés
meza muñoz y estos son nuestros
titulares la decisión del presidente de
túnez de concentrar todos los poderes
preocupa a varios sectores aún después
de la instalación de un nuevo gobierno
después de varias y masivas
movilizaciones de ciudadanos ahora los
periodistas exigen el libre ejercicio de
su profesión tras una serie de ataques
de los simpatizantes del mandatario y la
policía luego de diez años de ausencia
el ex presidente de costa de marfil
laurent gbagbo regresa a la política con
la creación de un nuevo partido por esta
medida el mandatario intentaría volver a
la presidencia tras la derrota electoral
de 2010 y el proceso judicial ante la
corte penal internacional por presuntos
crímenes de lesa humanidad con
movilizaciones en parís miles de
personas conmemoraron los 60 años de la
brutal represión contra una protesta de
manifestantes argelinos en la capital
francesa que reclamaba la independencia
de su país el suceso terminó con la
muerte de al menos 120 argelinos
empezamos en túnez aunque hay un nuevo
gobierno este sigue operando en
circunstancias excepcionales desde que
el presidente de caixa ayer decidió
suspender el parlamento destituir la
administración anterior y otorgarse
poderes legislativos y ejecutivos por un
periodo indefinido aunque el mandatario
ha intentado tranquilizar a la población
diciendo que protegerá los derechos y
las libertades algunos grupos están
preocupados ante esta situación sin
precedentes
una multitud de periodistas realizó un
plantón el jueves 14 de octubre ante la
sede de su sindicato nacional desde que
el presidente se otorgó poderes
especiales en túnez en medio de un clima
político tenso han aumentado las
agresiones contra los reporteros este
periodista de la televisión nacional fue
agredido por manifestantes que
protestaban contra el presidente
nosotros cuando sacamos el logotipo de
la televisión nacional para poner el
micrófono y hacer mi presentación
directo nos atacaron con botellas de
agua y piedras lanzadas por los
manifestantes y a mí me golpearon con
una piedra en la cabeza caí al suelo no
me desperté sino hasta que estaba en la
sala de urgencias en la fila de l'estany
y otros ya no pueden trabajar los
periodistas del medio al yazira vieron
como la policía cerró su cd después del
25 de junio breve de turner enfermedad
nos impidieron filmar en la calle y
asistir a conferencias de prensa sin
ninguna decisión judicial sin ninguna
explicación de las autoridades
explicación
y esta falta de claridad se extiende al
parlamento cuya actividad está congelada
desde el 25 de julio porque según caixa
ayer representa un peligro para el país
este diputado apoyó la suspensión del
parlamento por quedar incapacitado en
los conflictos pero hoy lamenta la falta
de control y equilibrio
desde el punto de vista jurídico no hay
forma de apelar las decisiones
presidenciales es que esto me parece
demasiado e inexplicable podríamos haber
acudido fácilmente a la mesa de
negociaciones dirigir un diálogo sobre
cómo volver a la normalidad también para
asegurar que las instituciones funcionen
en beneficio de la sociedad y la
población y que la democracia vuelva a
ser una democracia efectiva
el presidente de caixa ayer ha hablado
hasta ahora que necesita un período de
un año para reformar el sistema político
pero no ha prometido que se vaya a
restablecer el parlamento
el ex presidente de costa de marfil
laurent gbagbo hizo oficial su regreso a
la política con la creación de un nuevo
partido el llamado partido popular
africano busca reunir a la izquierda y
con él el exmandatario intentaría volver
a la presidencia para las elecciones de
2025 bajo había estado ausente durante
10 años en 2011 fue detenido y
extraditado a la haya para ser juzgado
ante la corte penal internacional por
presuntos crímenes de lesa humanidad
tras la violencia desatada luego de las
elecciones de 2010 cuando se negó a
aceptar la derrota el conflicto cobró la
vida de unas 3.000 personas en 2019 fue
absuelto y se mudó a bélgica hasta junio
de este año cuando regresó a costa de
márfil escuchemos lo que dijo el ex
mandatario
[Aplausos]
estar en política está mal muerte
de sedes q
según él wazzen pero lo digo al final de
este discurso shuttle form soy yo y sólo
yo el que decidir de qué forma voy a
hacer política
soy yo y sólo yo quien decidirá en qué
forma continuaré mi lucha qué forma
cinco meses después de haberse declarado
el fin de la última pandemia de ébola la
organización mundial de la salud
detector nuevos casos del virus en la
república democrática del congo al
momento de grabar este programa se
habían detectado cinco contagios desde
el pasado 8 de octubre y tres de ellos
murieron las autoridades creen que este
nuevo brote parecía estar relacionado
con el que surgió entre 2018 y 2020 y
que causó la muerte de más de 2.200
personas desde que se detectaron los
primeros casos este mes se inició una
campaña de vacunación mientras se hace
el monitoreo y rastreo de cientos de
contactos
miles de personas se reunieron en parís
para conmemorar el aniversario número 60
de la brutal represión contra una
protesta de migrantes argelinos el 17 de
octubre de 1961 los manifestantes entre
ellos asociaciones argelinas y grupos de
derechos humanos recorrieron las calles
de la capital para rechazar este hecho
la movilización se dio un día después de
que el presidente francés emmanuel
macrón reconociera la responsabilidad
del estado por estos crímenes que
calificó como imperdonables hace 60 años
numerosos argelinos se manifestaron en
parís en reclamo de la independencia de
argelia y contra la colonización
francesa pero la marcha no quedó ahí
sino que fue objeto de una violenta
represión policial se cree que cientos
fueron ahogados en el río sena el
recuento de aquel contexto en este
sketch de adele gasteiz
en
1954 el ejército de liberación nacional
de argelia emprende su guerra de
independencia contra el colonialismo
francés
el presidente del consejo entonces quimo
le da pleno poder a los militares galos
[Música]
su intervención es rápida y violenta y
los oficiales someten a una cruel
tortura de los detenidos argentinos
es así como la rebelión argelina entra
de lleno en la escena política de
francia con tal crisis que pone fin a la
cuarta república en 1958 interviene el
general y pronto presidente es charles
de gaulle los argelinos perciben en su
discurso cierta flexibilidad y se
manifiestan en reivindicación de sus
libertades el frente de liberación
nacional se pone a la cabeza con una
marcha que cubre a francia
pero los argelinos llamados franceses
musulmanes de argelia son obligados a un
toque de queda tras 20 horas
deciden saltarse lo y salir a protestar
el 17 de octubre de 1961
[Música]
en esa época movice papón es el jefe de
la policía parisina documentos y
testimonios dan fe de su rol en la
represión y asesinato de los
manifestantes
muchos de ellos fueron golpeados por la
policía otros ahogados en el río sena
a 60 años de los hechos el estado
francés ha admitido la masacre pero aún
debe esclarecer la memoria sobre la
guerra de argelia
pasamos a kenia donde más de 2 millones
de personas están en riesgo de hambruna
debido a más de dos años de sequía
grabados por una plaga de langostas y la
pandemia de kobe 19 el acceso a los
alimentos es una preocupación urgente
tanto para los seres humanos como para
el ganado en medio del progresivo
impacto del cambio climático si la
temporada de lluvias entre octubre y
diciembre es inferior a lo esperado la
situación humanitaria seguirá empeorando
el informe es de juan pabló lucumí
yunís y su hija de 5 años de recorrer
hasta 5 km de distancia para recibir
donaciones de alimentos
después de haber pasado tres días sin
comer llega al centro del pueblo de
campo donde recibe aceite de cocina y
harina de maíz debe posicionar las
ayudas para que le dure al menos una
semana
como ya hace ya casi tres días que mi
familia y yo pasamos sin llevarnos nada
parecido a la comida a la boca
a
convencionales
y hoy estoy contenta porque he
conseguido algo de comida de la cruz
roja y estoy segura que me durará al
menos seis días y después de estos seis
días la vida volverá a hacer
barbosa como yunís más de dos millones
de personas afrontan el hambre según la
autoridad nacional de gestión de la
sequía producto dos años de escasas
lluvias y una plaga de langostas que
tiene un impacto directo en la
agricultura mientras que el
calentamiento global es una de las
causas de la sequía en la zona ríos
lagunas y presas se han secado en las
zonas de pastoreo de animales y de
agricultura
we have to look for cisvi debido al
cambio de clima tenemos que buscar
semillas que sean climáticamente
inteligentes y aprobadas por el clima no
semillas de tu abuelo ni semillas de tu
abuela ni semillas de tu padre hay que
buscar semillas que hayan sido
modificadas por los agrónomos para que
se adapten a las condiciones actuales
debido al cambio climático y esas son
las semillas que te ayudarán a tener
algo de comida en la mesa al 12 decir
suicide health
cuando los aldeanos dicen que llueve
cuando no debe hacerlo y sus terrenos se
secan cuando no se espera esto ha
complicado la distribución de semillas
pastos y alimentos
cotonú benin es la capital económica del
país y también se está convirtiendo
rápidamente en uno de los principales
centros tecnológicos de áfrica allí
richard aislado se está haciendo un
nombre con una serie de productos de
alta tecnología france24 fue averiguar
más sobre él y su empresa cuya
reputación ha traspasado fronteras
richard estrada sueña con convertirse en
uno de los jóvenes constructores del
futuro de áfrica está decidido
establecer su marca africana azúcar
spirit entre los nombres más importantes
de la industria tecnológica su último
producto estrella son estas gafas
inteligentes simplemente contestó al
hacer esto porque escuchó el teléfono
sonar en mis lentes con este sistema
proteges tus ojos protegidos por sonidos
proteins tu vida es la vida de los demás
mostrado ha sido un apasionado de la
electrónica desde su adolescencia ahora
está experimentando un rápido éxito
estos dispositivos de alta tecnología
cuestan hasta cuatro veces menos que
marcas famosas similares desde
computadoras con piezas reemplazables
gafas y relojes inteligentes antirrobo
todas sus creaciones encarnan la
identidad cultural africana decidimos
cambiar las cosas crear productos que
sean como nosotros y hablarnos azúcar
significa espíritu guerrero no
conocíamos ninguna computadora con
nombres africanos así que hicimos
computadoras andy chango es la divinidad
africana y psicológica su poder tras un
viaje lleno de obstáculos el joven
emprendedor ya ha vendido cerca de
20.000 productos toda la gama está
diseñada en benin y sólo se fabrica
temporalmente en el extranjero cree que
promover la innovación tecnológica es la
mejor solución para hacer frente al
desempleo hoy en día asesora jóvenes
propietarios de empresas emergentes con
ideas innovadoras pero sin respaldo
financiero
si necesita 500 millones y no puede
encontrarlos incorpore a las personas
adecuadas intercambia habilidades a
cambio de acciones
desde nuestra acaba de obtener un
respaldo financiero para desarrollar su
marca al proporcionar soluciones hechas
a medida para el continente su objetivo
es alcanzar o superar a los gigantes de
alto rendimiento presentes en áfrica y
finalizamos este capítulo de áfrica
siete días con imágenes que llegan desde
sudáfrica específicamente de la ciudad
de everton donde el olor a neumáticos
quemados y las nubes de humo se vieron
nuevamente en las pistas de spinning una
disciplina que consiste en hacer
derrapar los vehículos y que formaba
parte del ritual de los gánsters durante
la época de la partida pero que de un
tiempo para acá se convirtió
oficialmente en un deporte ahora los
torneos volvieron tras casi dos años de
haber estado en pausa a raíz del brote
de kobe 19
con estas imágenes despedimos este
capítulo de áfrica siete días recuerda
que si quieres repetir esta u otra
misión de nuestro programa lo puede
hacer a través de nuestra página web www
puntos 24 punto com
[Música]